[Music]
when our noodle propeller super lemon
haze you the Diego and Salma prepara
quintet resigns live as commence assault
vehement investment Santa Anna e total
Azura's don't remain run tansy and
Cawood fins a buoy and cervical a show
those measures are ones that must tell
if it is and see what does not move
cannot measure an area
chef pilot petrissage a monkey you know
people you monkey you're gonna have a
sale in time type of stars on Maxim
hostility it's windy up there Ian I know
it's not your fault but uh everybody two
people already in project
Sakha bhava who I'm not fashionable
I'm sure you'd rather be up in the
mountains just over the way right now
than sitting here in the studio this is
like I think we have how many people do
we have in here this is like wow we're
performing for an audience today I've
wanted to meet you for a very long time
you're a huge inspiration to me and I'm
just delighted to talk to you so I
appreciate you taking time out you're
and you just got in you just told me
you've been in like 20 different places
in the last like two weeks or something
like that your time code must be
completely upside down yeah but I think
it's good because we're changing like
timezone every day it's good because you
don't know where right where you are
when you are so like you don't feel any
that like it's just like the Moto these
days like if you have 10 minutes and you
can't sleep sleep because you don't know
when it will be the next time right
right right well thirst
anybody who can endure endure this I
think it's you so you're you're you're
perfectly suited to be able to manage
that kind of crazy schedule and first of
all before we even get into it like
congratulations you have a baby coming
on the way yeah thank you it's exciting
yeah probably yeah
exciting and scary in the same way but
yeah really it yeah looking forward
anything like when you will need to work
in logistics the next year yeah yeah
things we're gonna change a little bit I
would imagine yes or no you're looking
at me like no they're not gonna change
yeah no like yeah of course like they
will change and especially like because
both me and Emily my my girlfriend like
we both do the same lifestyle so like we
will need to decide like who is racing
which race so the other can like be
babysitting when they are the Racing's
yeah yeah yeah that is a little bit of
an adjustment I would imagine because
for people that are listening I mean
Emily is an incredibly accomplished
ultra runner in her own right you guys
were just in Nepal right and she was
doing FK T's like recently yeah actually
she was this summer like she was doing
some FK T's in some 4000 meter Sammis in
the Alps like mum blah
and unmoor rose and then like she was
doing some like long-distance run like
300 mile running in Sweden and all these
when she was pregnant like she didn't
know at the time but huh and yeah we
were in Nepal now like and she was just
climbing up to 5,000 meters or 1,700
feeds on yeah nah not feeling good yeah
right so five and a half months pregnant
so that means sometime this winter yeah
yeah it'll be winter baby that's that's
good like just out they called does that
change how you think about risk and how
you calculate you know the challenges
that you want to undertake it's like
it's hard to know because like risk
right risk is nothing that it's
objective it's something that is very
subjective like it's it's it's more a
feeling that that that mathematic think
and I seen it change all the time like
sometimes you go to take - to do a climb
and like you always calculate okay it's
it's these objective things like it can
be avalanche or it can be like a select
falling or crevasses or like the
technical skills you need and then you
decide if you are yeah if you can do it
or not but then it's something a feeling
that sometimes like you say I can do
that but I don't feel for it right and
other times is like okay I feel that
it's I'm in the flow and I can do all
these so it's yeah I think it's many
things that affect that and probably
like having a baby can change that but
then I have friends that they have
babies and they continue doing the same
so my thing I will need to discover when
it comes yeah I think you'll know when
it happen to suppe as somebody else for
kids it's hard to anticipate beforehand
but then when the event occurs there's
something that changes I think in your
in your I don't know your emotional
being or your you know your sense of
self that that like everything you do
has an impact on this other person like
when you're talking about risk
calculation it's very much an internal
it sounds like you're you're just
calculating this internally like how do
I feel how do I feel like I can let you
know whether I can handle this or not
but then in the back of your mind
thinking well there's this other person
who's relying on me like I'm I'm curious
as to whether that will impact that or
maybe not I don't know
yeah it's it's it's very interesting I
think because like when you yes you say
like we don't know like how it will
affect them because it's because it's a
feeling is not like saying okay we have
a kid so like I will not do that or I
will do that because you don't know how
you will feel and at the end like you
can calculate and take original decision
of doing a thing but then the feeling it
will say something like no like it's it
looks so cool I need to go there even if
it's these yeah this possibility of
ratio anyway I need to go on yeah yeah
yeah I will see ya bye Jinta Alan Adi
and missile people civil or no novice is
your the new portable eame porno to
their managers quarters fixers mother
sees you there are no referral you need
a fat - cetera terminal / petra's
decisions yourself since the nuna
personal campus accomplish the quads of
all cosas de sorted is the compassionate
Satyam total material denote anyways
Allah Montaigne knowns yoga recover CL
tentacle stars are Maxim Allah still lb
most conditions Damian
[Music]
within the world of multi-sport and
endurance and ultra endurance I mean
everybody knows who you are they know
your accomplishments there's a lot of
people that listen to this that don't
necessarily come from that world but
perhaps they became familiar with you
because of the Everest expedition that
you went on in 2017 so can we talk about
that a little bit yeah for sure yeah I
mean that that made headlines across the
world in a five or six day period you
you summit it twice so I want to walk
through that but maybe even before that
specifically how did you prepare for
that how did you wrap your head around
getting ready for to do something like
that and what was it that you were
seeking to accomplish well I think the
preparation is it's like a long one and
a short one which like the long one it
starts like very very long time ago when
I was like probably three or two years
old yeah so like I think it's it's not
that you decide okay next week I want to
go to Everest and what they do or like
next month or next year but like you
need to have a background or like a long
period of training before before being
able to do some things is like when you
raise like it's not that you decide okay
I want to do one like Western stage or
hard rockin and you start preparing and
the months after you are able but I was
starting when I was kid to go to the
mountains and to start to do like long
days out then racing so it was like
during like has been training for more
than 15 years like yeah the last 15
years I has been training at least 1,000
hours a year so that's the like the
background and then in top of that
during the last the last two months
before going to to Everest it was more
specific preparation so actually they
the
the different thing compared to only
endurance training or like more
technical climbs it was to prepare to be
really confident and to be really
comfortable in situations that you are
not supposed to be comfortable yeah so
for example like I was there okay if
some problem arrives up there I will be
by myself and I will have not any help
so I need to be able to get to take the
good decisions and for that like I was
going to drink home and to to do very
long days like sometimes like 15 20 or
more hours alone and in some situations
that they were a bit risky like that I
needed to be always intention for
avalanche or for things and to put
myself in the in the really like limit
on my technical skills to be always in
this yeah tension situation and to be
able to take decisions on a reasonable
way and not to let the motion to
interact on that yeah right so on some
level it's a natural progression of
everything you've been doing your whole
life since you were 3 years old since as
long as you can remember like I think
there was a quote where somebody said
how long did it take you to prepare and
you're like well my whole life right
this is this is your life yeah and as
somebody who's been training you know a
thousand twelve hundred hours in the
mountains you know per year for many
many many years it seemed to make sense
as the culminating point of this you
know summits of my life thing that you
were doing but I would imagine there
were specific things around a client
like you're somebody who who I mean you
have a your resting heart rates like
thirty four or something like that you
have a crazy vo2 max like 92 right oh
yeah thousand twelve I mean for
perspective like I think Lance Armstrong
was 85 like it's crazy high so you have
these you know these these perhaps
genetic or created gifts that have that
are result of the training that you've
done and your upbringing but there were
also I would imagine specific things
that you had to do to get ready for
acclimatizing even though you
acclimatize better than most people and
I think I've read you you were training
with like oxygen deprivation or like
masks on on the bike and on the
treadmill and things like that to try to
expedite your ability to to acclimate
once you got there yeah well as you said
acclimatization is something very
important before expedition and
especially like the goal of the of the
whole thing it was to try like to to
don't spend too much time in in the
mountain like in the travel first for
two things because I'd like to do many
things so like embracing and climbing
and skiing so I didn't want to spend
like three four months in in in a base
camp like just sitting right and then
because like I think if you arrive at
climatized
in a mountain like you are fresher like
mentally so you keep the motivation and
also you are physically stronger because
you you came from home it has been
eating well it's not like you are in a
base camp just eating fried rice like
for a month and then like so the goal
was to arrive in the mountain already
acclimatize and for that I has been
doing the last five years different
expeditions and trying different things
most of them didn't work and this year I
think we we finally get what what work
it and actually it was like home before
departing we were spending like around
300 hours in altitude so both sleeping
like in the night we were sleeping in in
hypoxic or tent at 6000 meters and then
during the days in the morning I was
doing my normal training like five to
ten hours in the mountain and in the
afternoon I was doing like one one hour
everyday a very intense like I will say
like in the in the dress roller like
even higher like anaerobic intervals
during
at 6000 meters innovation mm-hmm and
could you feel the difference when you
got there did you feel like you had you
know expedited the process of being
comfortable at that kind of altitude
yeah it was it was cool because like
normally the first day you arrive at
6000 meters coming from from Europe you
arrive in the mountains and like you see
like okay yeah I feel like right at
that time it was like at 6,000 meters
first day we were able to run and like
three days after coming to duty bit we
were able to climb to 7,000 meters and
feeling good so it was a huge difference
I think to feel it for 6,000 yeah yeah
so for for most people that attempt
Everest it there's a period of weeks
where they're kind of inching their way
up and getting used to it and all of
that so that they can be as safe as
possible for the summit and you're
compressing that into literally a number
of days and so how long were you there
before you're like okay you know
tonight's gonna be the night yeah like
we were actually before going to Everest
like I I fly from Europe with Emily and
we were going to show you that it's a
mountain just by the side I thousand
meters summit so we were going there and
we spent like 10 days in show you and
then so I reached it I don't think the
summit but the summit plateau so around
eight thousand two hundred meters and
then I was driving to to Everest base
country just like a couple of hours from
there and then it took like one week to
feel ready so I would say like between
two to three weeks period is worried
like if you are a climatized from Rome
like you know right right and right
beforehand I were you like running up
you know a thousand meter a sense like
in under an hour like getting ready like
people are like what are you doing yeah
like I I think like it's cool to the
things and especially like in base camp
it's very very boring like you are
sitting in a wonderful place like you
have beautiful mountains all around
and you are sitting in a tent doing
nothing like that's not like what I want
to know that you know so like okay you
need to rest like like the year before I
wanted to do everything like everything
every day so I was doing a lot every day
and then like after one week I was
completely destroyed right so this is K
I say okay I will need to rest a bit but
we figure out like one interesting one
day activity it's enough so yeah they
like it was a one day often than the
other day like you could like if you are
well acclimatized like I think going up
to 8,000 meters it's is not this hard
like and you can run up and Nolan you
can walk slowly up and run down kind of
but it's fine yeah
and so the first attempt you decide to
start at like 50-100 meters right yeah
which is lower than then where most
people start yeah normal example right
yeah normally people like a start from
the like the final push that it takes a
few days from ABC advanced breast cancer
that's at the feet of the mountain at
6300 meters but I twenty-two get there
it's a long long hike right like maybe
13 miles and from drum book it's worth
the road test like it's alright it's a
road that finished there so I wanted to
like the goal of the of the whole
expedition it was not to set a fkfk teen
in the mountain because like it's you
cannot talk about FK t in these high
mountains because conditions and style
make huge difference so it was mostly to
try to go from the last village to the
summit and back and only with my means
like calling all the year I needed and
not having any assistance because of
then I wanted to know if I was able to
climb the mountain by myself or if I
wasn't right so there's a there's the
you know the spirit behind all of this
is a sense of purity like that infuses
everything that you do which is
first of all like can it be done and can
it be done without all of the gear like
how how minimal can this be accomplished
right just with man and mountain and
nothing else
yeah like oh I seem like as animals we
are a mammal and we are a berry but
adapted animal to the mountains like
because like as you see like you can see
like the fastest man on earth like using
bolt he runs like around 40 kilometres
an hour
400 meters and that's probably like what
a cow can run so like we are by far not
the first animal and if you've seen the
mountains I use we were in Nepal or in
Tibet and you see the yaks and like we
are there like big down jackets and we
need to eat a lot you to keep fitness in
altitude and you see this yak that is
staying there for weeks he eats one time
a week like just kind of grass he is not
drinking anything he's not gonna like
you though uh yeah no we I am very far
from there so like so like we need to
have some gear we need to have some that
but to try to get us closest we are as
an animal to climb yeah mm-hmm and all
right so the first attempt from 50-100
meters you make it to the summit twin
26 26 26 hours okay and no ropes no
supplemental oxygen unbelievable like
what was the the hardest part of that
for you mmm well like the hardest thing
in the first lesson is that hey I feel
like I had a stomach problem yeah you
ate something bad yeah yeah like I eat
something but probably the day before
like in the base camp so at the
beginning I was feeling okay for a few
hours but then I started to have like
diarrhea and vomiting so I decided to
stop eating to avoid that but they're
like energy goes low so like during the
last hours to the summit
very very slow it's not like it's not
hard on a way that they're like it's
more like only two decisions like you
are saying okay is these gonna kill me
and if it's yes then you turn and if
it's not then you continue so like male
when your stomach's turning on you and
say look I'll just do this you know I'll
go reboot and do it again another day
like did yeah that decision to continue
put me were you too far into it or what
was the decision to persist yeah mostly
it's like it's very long life from
rumble yeah until you get to the
mountains like it's these 13 miles in
the moraine it's it's painful like it's
it's not fun so then I was there I was
like almost when I either said okay now
it it will be hard yeah yeah that's and
then I was at 8,000 meters so he's like
okay should I go all the way back and
start it again like a couple days or
like anyway like I'm here it's I will go
slow but I will not die and somehow it
will be some fun so why not to continue
and yeah fun for you yeah it's a special
fine yeah yeah so you do that but then I
presume a because of that stomach
illness or a sense of knowing that you
could do it faster or better you make
this decision to go once again yeah it
was some it was funny like I was going
down from the first summit I'm doing the
downhill I I was thinking okay like we
still have like five days till the plane
leaves from Lhasa to home so we had some
extra lights in the base camp is nothing
to than the base camp so instead of like
packing during one week like it was like
I was thinking okay why not to try to go
up again not for the doing a first time
because I knew that I will be very tired
after this first test but also it we
started to interest like if it would be
possible to recover fast and to see how
the recovery effects on your CV yeah if
it was possible yeah and from from what
I understand is
you know being somebody who's never
attempted anything like that but people
who really understand this that's the
most miraculous aspect of all of this
which is that it generally takes
somebody weeks to kind of recover from
an experience like that before they're
prepared or physiologically ready to
attempt another summit but just
literally days later you decide to go
again and I think it speaks to your
natural ability to recover more quickly
than the average human being on some
level but also like what is that like do
you just felt like internally you did a
gut check and you know like I'll be fine
I feel good yeah I think it was um I
fell I fell okay like you feel tired
that is like okay yeah I can move so but
mostly I think the recovery it's because
we had been long in the mountain so like
as I said before like with the first
acclimatization and with the being like
short travel like we were there and I
was still fresh on kind of like
motivation and like healthy like strong
and in the other side like I never slept
high in the mountain like all the nights
I spend it was always maximum it was six
thousand three hundred meters so like
not sleeping high it makes a big impact
rather for the recovery then you need to
be able to go to the Sun it like from so
do a long elevation from 6,000 meters so
it's it's very long days but it's good
night so that makes us so good for
recovery and yeah like during the second
as like I was feeling tired like
normally but it was I think it was
better than what I expected like I was
able to kind of hook was there anybody
in your your contingent your group of
people who who pulled you aside and said
maybe you should weigh a little bit
longer or do they is trust you that you
know yourself well like these group of
people
it was only one person so it was a
seven-month pass so that was it maker
the film it was him and me and the good
things like we did that have like kind
of much internet or any or satphone so
it was like I was only just sending like
maybe every few days like a message to
my team or my family saying ok
everything is ok we are right we are
good so we don't have much input now you
have more people with you here today
yeah and that second time up the
conditions were worse right there was it
was snowing and windier yeah it was
supposed to be the best day in the
summer or in the spring like all the
like big grooves like Adrian Ballinger
they were climbing the that day also
like the the swiss expedition curry
curry cobbler they were climbing this
day so they were saying dad's the day is
Mike the best one on the on the season
so I was saying ok that's that's cool
here and then we started climbing the
the bad weather was coming faster than
the supposed and because I did not have
any radio or any kind of communication
with the others they could not tell me
and then like I saw like it was okay the
sky is a bit more wide and but it was
windy but but not that bad like is not
win that it throws you away the face oh
yeah right and and so you summit and
this time you started from advanced base
camp right so that was like yeah if I
100 yeah this time yeah actually after
the first summit I was going down to the
base camp then actually we lost yeah
yeah no that that the second time but
the day after the first time like we
were packing everything to get ready for
living last because I knew ok if I go
back
to the savvy like it will be super speed
after so we pack everything and then we
went up to ABC to 1600 and then we do
not have any ten there but it was a
alpenglow that they had an expedition
there and they were up in the mountains
so we could sleep in their dining room
right and then I started from from there
yeah then going down I I get lost from
the mountain that was kind of fun Maria
yeah and you end up perilously close to
that North Face Ridge right the drop-off
yeah it was um it was strange like I
think like now like I has been talking
with a lot of doctors and start to
understand why I had I had a blackout
period during a few minutes so actually
I was climbing and it was fine it was
windy so like the tracks and the it was
cover like even like in spring climbing
you cannot talk about Alpine style
because even if I wasn't using the fixed
ropes like it's it's the second letter
or the third letter in the second step
that I use it and then it's the fixed
ropes there so like even if you don't
use it like it's easy to to follow the
way because they are there but during
the second awesome
we thought the bad weather like it was
snowing a lot and windy so all the ropes
and all the tribes were cover but that
was okay and in the way down I remember
very well like until Ivory's the eight
thousand six hundred meters but from
there I have like a blackout parrot I
don't know what it happened and how you
got there like I think he said you
thought you were gonna wake up from a
dream and be at base camp yeah yeah
because from there like the next memory
was like I was down climb being
something technical in a big face I know
I was not anymore in a Ridge where I was
supposed to be but in a big face
there's no way Rocky is like where I am
what I'm doing here it's dissident
because I didn't have any connection
with the last memory so I didn't know if
it was
reality or if it was a bad dream and I
was going to wake up in the base camp
and yeah the the bath or the worst thing
it was like I didn't know where I was so
I didn't know if I was in the north east
face or in the north face or in the
south face so it was like okay it's in
the middle of the night is whether
whether I'm in a phase on either
I have no absolutely no idea how do you
keep it together
how do you avoid panicking how do you
avoid you know your emotions getting the
best of you when you're in a moment like
that yeah I think that's that's what you
need to prepare for and to feel as I
said before feel confident in situation
that you are not supposed to be
confident to be comfortable it is
exactly these kind of situations and I
think it's it just to really accept
until to mentally accept before going to
an expedition what you can find there
and do not be surprised when these
situations arrive because they are
possible and I think when I was there it
was like it was more like a checking
saying okay I am called no I will not
die because I I will have like froze
pies or like hypothermia I didn't feel
any edema like brain edema or or like
they must I was saying okay this is okay
this is okay the only problem is that
denied and I don't know where it is but
I will not die because it's night and I
will not die because I don't know what
it where I am so then it was like okay I
just need to to figure out these two
things like the night it is like you
know wait until it's die light so you
can see where you are and then it was
mostly to to know that and I was fizzy
physically feeling good so I was
thinking okay I'm at 8,000 meters at
that time I was between eight thousand
two hundred and eighty thousand meters I
was there okay if I'm by I don't know
how in the South face and I need to
climb up again to 8,500 it will be hard
but I feel like physically okay to doing
it so I wasn't afraid of like need to go
up again or two
Yeah right it's like really to
compartmentalize all of these things and
be as logical as possible and not let
your emotions or any fear creep into how
you're making those decisions yeah I
think emotions yep in high mountains are
adventurers and it can be feared like if
you panic in a situation like that
probably you the mistakes and then you
fall but also like before you're like if
you are summiting and in the summit like
you start to to have like adrenaline and
you start to feel wow that's done and
unlike excitement then probably during
the doubt he like you will do mistakes
because you don't take care so I think
both good and bad emotions up there like
any emotion is bad you know yeah in
normal yeah so that's something I would
imagine you've just learned over the
many years of just always being in the
mountains and being and you know
countless situations where risk was a
huge factor yeah more yeah we learn a
lot of mistakes I would say I'm doing
mistakes having accidents or doing
stupid things we all do and these
situations that you when you come home
is like wow
today was very very stupid and it's
there when you learn when you say okay
next time I need to the weather yeah and
your your adventures have not been
without some consequences to some loved
ones I mean I know you were out with
Emily and you know outside Sean Mannion
and you had to be rescued and you've
lost a couple friends so I would imagine
that does that weigh on you when you're
out there sure like we do an activity
that we know that it's possibly like
weak and either in the mountain and it's
nothing that we look and we are not
doing that because they because we are
close to this but because we are alive
when we're doing but is the possibility
of yeah of an accident and when you have
some close calls it can be like
yes some friends that they died by your
side or it can be like some accidents
but all the times I think it's funny
that when you start to do mountaineering
like you are afraid about your
capacities because you don't know
yourself but you see the mountainous
something solid that it's it's there
it's like a ball or it's something and
more you go into the mountains less you
are afraid about yourself you know
better your capacities your technique
your experience but you see that the
mountain it's moving and it's it's
dangerous there that you you don't see
what they are there so you are more
afraid about the mountain so it's this
thing that it's many things that you
cannot control like you can think
logically but then it avalanches come
what is supposed to not or like some
rock falling and things and you need to
accept in a way that that's part of it
that it's many things we can control
that it's some of them that is not
possible to do yeah I mean I look at you
as somebody who despite all of your
accomplishments you know is is very
humble like you have a very healthy
relationship with humility and not to
project but I would imagine that comes
from an appreciation and respect for
nature like you're never gonna beat the
mountain right and if you don't have a
respect and a healthy level of humility
when you're attempting these challenges
and you're putting yourself at great
peril so keeps you like sort of
right-sized about everything yeah I
think conquering mountains is a very
very ironic word I think like we are not
conquering mountains up there like we
can't conquer itself and the mountain is
where we is this big mirror where we see
yourself but but we can never pretend to
to be fighting against a mountain or to
be finding against nature because first
of all because we are part of it like we
we are part of the nature so I think
it's important to to pass there lightly
so we can only see her four steps but we
like leaving no trace is not only like
about leaving rubbish but it's also
about like being being accepted by the
mountain or being try yeah kind of like
being there but trying to turn a grass
the mountain and I think on a way I
don't think that if you turn against the
mountain it will respect you more but at
least it keeps you aware of like okay
you are really really nothing you are
very very small even if you are like and
especially because the sports it's so
much about ego and how the sport is
organized like you win a race and you
are in a top of a podium that it's like
it's something very artificial like why
you are better because you run faster
than the guy that is second on one the
one is third or the one is Laswell so
we'd really like building kind of this
egg of centric mindset house powers
organized so you can think and it's easy
to believe that you are someone good or
that you are better than others and
especially Montagnes that's very
dangerous on and they're like it will
put in your side like yeah you are
nothing right yeah that's super
interesting you know and I think
impactful coming from somebody who's I
mean you basically won every big race
that there is to win you stood atop all
these podiums until there was really no
no challenge left for you to conquer
other than it seems to make perfect
sense in retrospect that you would then
go on to this summits of my life
experience because just you in the
mountain and you without any fanfare
well there's probably some fanfare
wherever you go but but you know without
the structures and the kind of logistics
of racing to be able to just go out on
these mountains and make it as pure as
possible and see how fast you can go up
and back and have that experience just
for yourself
summons of my life bar sale projecting
above a certificate moment the three
stairs another the Posada that I
completed our son is Catania Canada name
and the yamame somnus Kissimmee Hawaii
is sonicate project
Summit's of my life is Upendra is Vyasa
puja Vasa
emissary racemes una manera Youngjae de
la Vida assistance
basic amenities passive element Anya II
issue
I normally like solitude and I like yeah
kind of like being alone being along
with with mountains it's it makes sense
on the way that it's this feeling like
this feeling of feeling very small it's
it's very interesting I thing and unn
facing yourself and of course in
Racing's you can find great challenges
because like racing at the end like at
the beginning it was like a pure
competition motivation but I want to win
the race or I want to became world
champion or whatever and that really
drive me to to achieve that and I think
it's a very interesting process because
having this goal in mind you put so much
effort like it's it's easy to Train very
hard if you have this goal in mind but
at the end like when you achieve the
goal it's like the satisfaction it's
it's it's a second but then it's like ok
what one next and of course like doing
the same process is not as exciting but
actually I think now uh now racing it's
it's cool because it it gives me like
both like a motivation to train her to
do some kind of trainings like seeing
young people that it's going very fast
like and wanted to beat them it's like
but maybe sometimes when I'm training
like it gives me this like more
motivation to push a bit more the button
and then it's also good checklists like
if you are racing and you are doing good
performances it means that you are in ok
shape so I think that's that's important
after for going to mountaineering
because it means that I'm keeping good
in good shape and then that I can use
these rising shape for for going to
mountains but there I know that at the
end like I will be by myself and it's
it's only yeah a fight against yourself
yeah well a couple interesting things
about your training and your racing in
your preparation you don't have a coach
you haven't had a coach since you were a
kid
yes since uh since I was 17 years old
yeah yeah if you learned everything
there was to learn when that Coach now
you go you go out and from what I
understand like you don't really create
training plans it's more of uh this is
how I feel today and I'm gonna go out in
the mountains for two hours or 10 hours
or maybe I'll decide when I'm halfway
out there how long I'm gonna be out
there ya know it's not it's not that
fair yeah no no I can read so explain
yeah actually yeah I I was with a coach
until I was 17 so it was kind of
learning the basics like to be method II
conductivity follow like kind of
different what what it happens when you
do these volume trainings or when you do
like short intervals or long intervals
so I had this basic and then I like to
study like I spend a lot of hours every
week like just reading articles that
they come about physiology that they
come about psychology that they come
about training looking to what other
people is doing out there both in in in
climb being and in alter running but
also like in athletics and in like a
cycling and so I I really like to read
these subjects to understand how the
body works and to try things and
especially I like to try things like to
see how it works for example both in
training like for example doing thirty
thirty like thirty seconds super fast
and then resting thirty seconds like
during some periods of time I wanted to
really push that to the limit so I was
doing that like as long as possible
during like three hours or like doing
that only thirty thirty it's like all
the time yeah and they're like saying
what it was happening the next week
already journaling that writing it down
so you can look back and yeah I have an
excel with like all the trainings and
ideas since 2003
so yeah is everything it strikes me as
somewhat you strike me is very similar
to Alex Honnold in your approach and
your lifestyle and this you know the the
purest aspect and in what you do and I
think what gets missed in Alex's story
maybe not so much now that the
documentary is out is the rigorous
preparation that goes into his free solo
climbing and and it's the same with you
like people want to think well you're
just out there doing whatever but you're
very methodical in your own way about
how you approach your training and your
racing and the feedback that your body
is giving giving you I mean I've read
didn't you create also like the
spreadsheet of this chronology over the
course of history of what's required to
go fast in the mountains like you're a
student right you're a scholar of the
sport and the human in the human
physique yeah it can be geek sometimes
and yeah I have some that no I think it
is interesting and especially like to
understand what has been done before and
to understand what's what's going and
yes studying I think it's what makes us
interest to yeah like if we read a lot
what's going on and and if something new
is it's it's happening to understand why
and to understand how and to try to
apply that and I know that many things I
can try or I I can read like I would not
be able to to to use by myself because I
have not the capacities but it's
interesting to try and to see if it's
working or not and sometimes this this
test or these things can work on me and
other times it can work for other people
but it's interesting to to try idea what
is something that that you've changed
like over the last couple years and in
how you approach your training that was
different than what you were doing maybe
I don't know five or six years ago I
would say that I I take a bit more care
about resting today but that's not fully
true because I don't raise my daughter
you don't have a paradise or taper at
all from but-but-but tapering I think
like when you see like for example the
in the marathon athletes like Elliot
keeps yogi or these guys like data on to
my Tjader like the Train 20 last week
but they thing like on planning seasons
is important like to find some some
periods but mostly I would say like now
I think with the base of the last 15
years of training I'm able to to perform
in a ok level without doing very
specific training so like only like
training average it's like I'm able to
do some good results in in long and
short distance but then it's more about
like these specific training like as I
say like forever so it was this
acclimatization and doing this very hard
intensity training for in very high
altitude that was very interesting or
like so I think now maybe it's like I
have already the base and during these
last years is these more specific
trainings that I can put for some period
that this pair you can go from one week
to two three four weeks so that's yeah
that's what they change mm-hmm but it's
not unusual for you to go out and train
seven eight hours in the mountains and I
think you you go like you can go out for
seven hours without even any water right
you don't bring a lot of stuff with you
it's not like you're packing a ton of
food and drink when you did Denali you
only have like a liter of water for that
11 hours yeah is that true yeah yeah no
it's does the double-a have been my
second Everest no but yeah I even yeah I
can train for like 10 hours without any
water right or food and ice at least has
somebody studied that like what is it
that allows you to do that you're just
so efficient
I think it's years of doing like I
remember like when when we were kids
like maybe seven eight years old like we
work sometimes with my mother too
do like a 1015 hours walk and we didn't
bring water so we were very very thirsty
but but I think doing that like I don't
want people to start now to run but you
started but yeah when you were a
teenager didn't you try it you try to
see how many days you could go like
training without eating five days until
you passed out or something yeah and
that's what I was yeah that's what they
were saying before like it's no but but
it's very interesting to know where are
your limits and to experience divert
yourself like that time like it was like
many times when you are in a race and
you you miss one aid station it's like
okay I don't have food that you start to
panic over whatever like it's not
because you miss that that you will lose
your race and I think if you know like
when that time like I was 17 years old
and I was in university and I was like
far away from the racing season so it
was like yeah why to see how the body
can be efficient in different
metabolisms and how far away so it was
very interesting because I stopped
eating and I was training like not a lot
but like the normal like three between
two and four hours in the morning and
one hour in the afternoon you're not so
much ya know but like not very very
little and then like the the first day
like you are okay the second day you are
hungry but actually the endurance is the
same like I was able to run almost the
same pace for the 4 hour run the only
difference it was like I lose like a
power and speed like I was unable to do
a sprint and these was keep going like
the endurance I almost didn't lose at
all during five days then I pass away
and yeah I was really close to to the
University so I wake up and I was going
to do it but but then is interesting
because you know ok until five days I
don't really need to worry or like I
know that the fat aborning or and I
think then the body starts to be also
more efficient on
to use energy you also cross train quite
a bit you're skiing all winter
you're mountaineering you're doing a
variety of different things and I would
presume that keeps you fresh and keeps
you from burning out you know you see a
lot of ultra runners who explode on the
scene they have a season or two in which
they're crushing it and winning races
and then they either over train or they
get injured and then it's very difficult
for them to have a presence at that
level once again and you've been able to
maintain you know a consistent presence
at the top for for many many years I
mean it wasn't until like the last year
that you even really had any injuries
yeah yes you say it's um it's it's
interesting to see Wow
yeah why how many athletes they burn out
after two seasons and that's very common
in ultra running and probably because
people is training running so some much
like so many miles every week during
during like many years so I think the
the mileage there it really affects so
combining with other activities like it
can be cycling or I do like a scheme
like during six months like from
November to to end of April I don't run
a same single day it's on the only
skiing so like doing endurance
activities but that they are not the
same movements and both for the mind
like to change and to be excited to run
and to infer the UM for the body like to
use other muscles and other
articulations it's yeah it's very
healthy yeah what was it like being
injured really for the first time this
past year I mean you had two shoulder
surgeries and then you broke your fibula
yeah you in a food for a while although
you still managed to get on a bicycle
and ride around with a boot on and do a
push-up or two yeah yeah no I think like
injuries like the first one I really
like I the shoulder surgery it was
something I wanted to do so it was no
not like I had an accident and the day
after I right I stopped so it was
something that you just had to do no
I need to the one time I was saying okay
I do now so then you enter in a mindset
okay of doing that so I used that time
to to read a lot so when I was like
reading all the this chronology of of
things and then like studying us like a
lot of physiology so it was kind of fast
going because it was things going on and
I was prepared for that but then for
sure the feeble it was just an accident
I had a ski accident in a race so that
was a bit more like okay it has been
like three months top and now like two
months like on and back again so I
wasn't worried about coming back to
shape because I knew that after like
some recovery it will be okay but it was
more like okay now it's like one or two
more months like without doing anything
that's probably the first time in your
life you had a literally sit in a chair
yeah yeah it was long then also like I
didn't tell my doctor or what I was
doing so it was like I was starting to
cycle like with the with the with the
fella yeah with the boot so I was a
study of cycle okay it feels away so
after two weeks a table doctor can I
start cycling he started say yeah you
can start to do something she's already
been doing it yeah and same with running
like I was running some long-distance
things and then he was saying yeah you
can start gently so there's not an
advice for people right oh yeah listen
to your doctor but I think it's you can
do things like at the first weeks like I
could work a bit more my upper body or I
can work the other leg so I think not
stopping completely it's important for
what trying to however you could and
then you ended up I think it was three
and a half months after you suffered the
injury you won the marathon - mwah mwah
yeah yeah that was I didn't know how I
would be so that was interesting on that
but yeah no it was good I mean how much
running were you able to get in before
that race I was able to run during one
yeah like one month I would say or yeah
something like three weeks one month and
yeah like I did some long days some very
very long days and then some short short
running but but yeah it was like I
wasn't afraid about the amount of
running but I was more afraid about the
speed like on going a downhill very very
fast yeah yeah I mean speaking of
downhill I mean that's really where you
shine and where your style kind of comes
through you're like this ballet dancer
you know - prancing down these mountains
you know precarious very technical
trails with just incredible agility that
even the best ultra runners you know
marvel at and there's all these videos
of you with a GoPro attached to your
head and you're like on the precipice of
some Ridge where it's thousands of feet
down in each direction and it makes
everybody's pumps wet so it begs the
question of your relationship with fear
I mean people would say well he's he's
not afraid he doesn't have fear but
that's not really accurate is it no one
first I think is two things like fear
like it's important to keep your life
like if we were not afraid of anything
like we would climb 30 floors building
and jump because we are not afraid to
die and we would die so like fear it
keeps us alive like because it tells us
okay you are not ready for that or you
you cannot do that and in the other way
like every person have different skills
on what is used to do like I for me
probably smaller than jurors to be like
working in New York or like Los Angeles
in the streets because like I'm not a
city person though also I would start to
cross trees without afraid you yeah so
because you are not used to that that if
you are everyday in the mountains it's
like when you are in the highway if you
take your wheel and you just turn it
probably you will just have an accident
but you don't do that so it's the same
in the mountain like you put the feet in
the good place like I'm good on fall so
if you are if you know how to run like
the
you would Natalia yeah and we should
probably talk a little bit about your
upbringing I mean you grew up in the
mountains your parents were guides right
so you were hiking and mountaineering
from as long as far back as you can
recall yeah he does have my tips he has
did not sure like my my father was a
mountain guide and my mother she was
also passionate about about
mountaineering so since we were children
with my sister like we were going to do
do some Sammy's or to do some crossings
so that was kind of like everyday yeah
everyday activities were like going up
out in the night you're out in the
mountain so it was I don't think it
affects much like on on physiology like
on how my body was built maybe within
the ankles or that but it's mostly about
being comfortable and to to read the the
landscape when did you first realize
that you had this talent or I I don't
think I have like I am good running but
I don't seem he's a big talent but why
not um it's it's a stupid thing like it
just it's running I can still put the
feet after the other and that's all but
but you recognize that you have some
gifts I yeah like I think like I have a
morphology that if that up for for
running and that's like of course like
if I if my dream was to be a bastard boy
yeah like probably I would not go far
even if I put a lot of work because I
like one 170 so but then it's it's work
I think like yes the the the morphology
and some gems give you something and
then you need to put a lot of work and I
think I think it was mostly like when I
was like teenager I I wanted to do that
and I prioritize that over all other
things so I didn't want to socialize or
want to go parties or I didn't want to
go after school to do something I when I
was after school I wanted to go training
and perform so I think it's during that
time that you start to choose your way
and yeah put that words on it your
coming-out party was was it UTMB when
you were like 20 or 21 was that like the
first time where everybody kind of knew
who you were yeah yeah it's where you
were like winning bite on and they
thought you were cheating yeah yeah yeah
no it was it was funny because like I
before that like I already like worn
some sky races or like a ski
mountaineering World Cup and things so I
knew I had the level to one with him be
like and I prepared the race very well
like I was doing during doing the round
in two days and I knew that I was able
to run in in less than 20 hours so I say
okay I I can win that and if nothing
happens like I will be winning but then
like I think the the ultrarunning wall
at that moment it was very very close so
like it was they didn't think that
someone young could could winner isin we
see today like it's almost only like a
young guys winning the races but yeah
with much older people who'd been around
for a long time yes just show up out of
nowhere and win a race no no like at
that moment I was already I had already
like eight years of racing and
performing so but it was as that the
people were running they didn't look
around they you only look to alter run
so didn't they didn't know like what
other people was right you were you were
crushing it in in skiing ski
mountaineering and all these other races
yeah yeah like this descent year yeah or
the year before I want this guy running
World Cup on on this ski mountaineering
so it I think yeah I I think not running
experience is important but it doesn't
matter if you put like from 30 to 40
years or from like 20
2:30 or from 10 to 20 years old so it's
just like you need to have the amount of
miles but it can be before or after
right and in that race you were like
winning by ton and then near the finish
they detained you for like an hour and
question you yeah sure you had the right
gear or wanted to know like what was
going on and then they released you and
you still won by an hour yeah yeah it
was like I don't have a very good memory
of this first edition because I I put a
lot of like yeah I really wanted to the
rise and for me like run a hundred miles
it was like I will be able to do so I've
even talked about like going fast but I
he was that thing about keeping the
distance mm-hmm so during the race it
was very cool and then they started to
stop me like to check the gear like it
was a mandatory here at the time or not
to but and they were checking me like if
I had all the gear and they checked me
that like four five times during the
race and all the time it was there so 1
hour before finishing like just at the
top of the last climb they stopped me
and they give me the radio to the
recognition to the race detector and it
was like okay we know you are sitting
somehow you stopped here one hour like
we will find what are you doing and then
we decided we let you finish or not and
it was like what's going on here and
like I wanted to beat at that moment I'd
rather say okay let's let's go home and
keep in ski mountaineering and scatter
our secrets through you guys see and
then it was actually won one guy their
friend ever say no no just count down
like keep going finish and like you
would see that everything is good but at
that moment it was yeah not right how do
you think about ultra running how this
explosion of growth that it's that it's
had over the course of your career I
mean what it is now versus what it must
have been like back even I mean 2008
wasn't that long ago but it's changed
quite a bit it's become so popular in
ten years it has changed like at the
beginning it was
more in each sport it was not that many
people it was just a few races yeah in
10 years it's like prices everywhere I
don't know how many hundred miles is in
in US but it's like hundreds of hundred
miles and and that's that's insane is
like one race every weekend at least and
and so many participants like race is
about interested in Europe with more
than 10,000 runners and it's the good
thing I think that it keeps the the like
the soul of the sport like it's not
reformatting to something like like
illogical like I think the beauty of
those parties to the logical things like
Team B for example is running around the
mountain got something like you would do
like just for fun or like western stage
from A to B like you know in a nice
place and I think every race have his
charm and he's not only like about
performance but like the soul
yeah the soul and it keeps it's
interesting I don't think it's a it's of
course like it's an elite of the like
some fast run is that we want to go on
races and we want to perform but that's
not the big part of the sport the big
part of the sport is that everybody can
feel the same thing and like you can be
top athlete or you can be a new beginner
and you can be in the same race doing
the same path and experiencing something
similar and at least for the moment I
think it's keeping that and that's very
that's that's important in the community
you know it's an unbelievable community
of people and you being somebody who
likes your alone time likes to be out in
the mountains by yourself I mean I I
also see somebody who really embraces
and loves at the community and that
that's that's a big driver for you I
mean you race all the time you're at all
of these races like I don't know you 15
or 20 of these a year it seems like yeah
it's a lot of racing as you said
community it's something that it's it's
important because it's what makes the
sport living like if it's only like if
it would be like only top athletes
racing by themselves it has not sense
and
it's because it's this and I think it's
a it's a cool community it's people that
loves loves like challenging themselves
loves poor but they also like it's sort
of a connection with nature it's it's a
connection with the with the places and
especially here in us it's a big
difference I think with yield upon how
how these you need to be like kind of
related to the to the community and to
the place with the like all the hundred
mile races almost they require like a
trail service so you need to work on the
trails before you are able to to to
register for race so that's sort in
doing yeah I think that really cool
thing is that it's it's not only about
racing but it's also like I think
feeling you can feel the race in a
racing perspective but you can feel the
rise in our organizing perspective in a
volunteering or in a pacing and all all
have the same importance and I think
here especially in the u.s. it's you
feel that much more that they respect ya
the respect as much the pacer or the
volunteer than they than they want that
we insert them they than the participant
yeah that's something that's really cool
and unique about the world I think do
you think that you have a different
relationship with pain and suffering
than the average athlete like how do you
think about those things I don't like
pain but I accept that it's part of the
job you feel it in the same way other
people feel it obviously you only have
your own experience you have this
ability to tolerate it at a pretty high
level I mean was that hardrock race you
broke your collarbone it like mile 13
and still I just finished the race but
like won the race yeah but like it's
there like you don't drown with your
arms so it's like it's not yeah did you
just like did you know is broken right
away and put it like harness it somehow
like what did you actually do when that
occurred yeah it was very stupid of me
like acting and I was a bit embarrassed
like we were running and it was in the
beginning of the race
like mile I think it was my like mile 13
or something like that and then it was
these like it's more like just like
maybe only like 50 meters is no field
and I was saying okay I want to like it
will be fun to go in these no feel and
do like skiing and I was going there and
I was like gliding in the snow and then
I completely lost the control so I just
right we just keep the Rogues after and
I'm just trying to have a little bit of
fun yeah I'm there like okay it was like
okay I'm so stupid so I put the shoulder
back and then it was ok during like
maybe two or three miles because it was
still warm but then it started to beat
cooler so it started to be really
painful but then I figure out a way with
the bad pipe like to do log the the
shoulder and so on like yeah it was icy
when you are in a race like you can't
really put yourself through pain like
you just go on and like you don't think
too much about eaten yeah I mean I would
think that if the race was shorter
because the adrenaline rush can carry
you through something like that but when
you're dealing with you know the number
of hours that a hundred mile or entails
I would imagine that wears off at some
point yeah yeah I would not say his
pleasure it's not pleasant but but like
yeah it's it's only pain like it's it's
if he's not something dangerous like if
it was like if you break a leg and you
say okay if I continue like it will be
much worse then it's stupid to continue
but if it's only pain like I was
thinking anyway like what if I stop now
I will go to the hotel and I will have
pain anyway because because it will not
go away and I will just be sad because I
have pain and sad because I I am sitting
here I have been doing a long travel and
and I'm just sitting in a hotel so I
will be sad because I have pain but I
can run so I'll be less sad yeah running
exactly yeah that's like that's
bizarrely logical I suppose strange
universe of all the things that you've
done what what has been the most
challenging for you like it's always
easy when you have done something like
because you have been able to do it then
it looks like easy like you can put a
lot of effort on doing something but if
you not fail then it's like okay it was
not that hard so I think the hardest
things is always when you fail because
like it means that you need to like it
was not enough that's the time the
teachable moments yeah I think so and
for I think like one of the hardest
races I have been feeling it was a
Western stage 2010 like I was completely
unprepared I was running a lot a lot of
things like long distance runs just the
weeks before in Europe I came here and I
didn't think about like hit I was like
okay it will be hot but I like hot for
me it's like being like more than 20
degrees Celsius that I don't know how
that in in Fahrenheit that is like like
how we are now here in in Los Angeles is
way much hotter than for me it's hot so
then western stage it's it's like around
90 some degrees and I didn't expect that
at all and I was like okay I just run
like with without water and I will drink
in devastation so then I started to get
this right and I started to you have
crimes of the body and that was yeah for
sure like a big fight to the finish
right is there any allure for you to
tackle any of the road ultras like bad
water or does it have to be in the
mountains for you yeah I'm not a fan of
road
I normally only run in road when I cross
from trade to trail right bad Road New
York Marathon coming up for you no no
like oh no way like it's it's somehow
like inter like I have always these boys
here saying I should try one marathon
one time or to try to do like I don't
know a 10k or more AHA for a marathon
because it's interesting in terms of
training like I would like to Train like
flat during a period to be able to run
faster but in the other way is like I
want to do that and that and that and
that and that so I don't find the time
for doing that so I would not say that I
will never do a road marathon because
maybe one day I do but yeah for the
moment I don't think is what I focus on
yeah
what is what's driving all of this like
where does the motivation come from like
where is the muse like what's what's
behind the curtain here that's
propelling you is it a sense of wanting
to be the best version of who you are is
it a search for excellence or perfection
is it just connecting with nature like
what is the driving impulse for you I
think the driving imposes its happiness
simply it's like to to be happy and and
that's that's a easy answer but it's a
it's a deep an sorta vehicles where were
if our happiness is is on or knowing
myself challenging myself and seeing who
I am where I can go and experiencing
different things I think it's a lot
about experience and an experiencing
place is natural beers like I've run in
places that they are beautiful and
that's what it motivates me to go to one
place or another is too wide to go there
it's to see the beer from that point and
see the beauty of the natural is one big
motivation and if I can combine that
with with the inner challenge that it
can be be able like to
the question I am able to progress and
like I think achievement on the sense of
like doing things that you think that
they are not possible for you before
like all the effort you put to be able
to change these status from impossible
to possible it's something that gives
you a lot of yeah so is there a sense
when you're looking at a challenge where
you're like oh man that that scares me
or that I don't think I could do that
and then that's what gets you interested
or what does that calculus look like
when you're trying to think about what
the next adventure is going to be for
you yeah I think we need to be in the in
the edge of that like you need to be if
it's something like it's many phrases
that you go there and you know that you
will win and then it can happen many
things but but you think okay with the
people out there or like with the
preparation is it will not be a surprise
if I win and then like you finish will
you win but it's not an emotion because
like it's not very once raised ten times
before yeah or not that but just like
because you know that it's nothing that
it's surprising or there's nothing that
it's putting you on challenge and I
think the challenge is just where you
you think okay that that's maybe
possible or maybe not possible for me
and I think it's this language because
if you think okay I want to do like I
want to run a one marathon in in two
hours I know that that's impossible like
completely impossible for me so that
does not does not a goal that just a
dream and attempting that it will not
make sense because it's a yeah if he has
not any possibility so I think you need
to or like I find the challenge where it
really like singing for example I know
that if everything goes perfect and I
feel that and with this preparation and
with all these things it's a possibility
to do anything there is the the exciting
pond so then what are you thinking about
right now
like where
what are you looking at at the moment
that gives you that feeling
well I like polyvalence like a fun
season for me and it's it's not about
the pure performance on one thing but
it's also like on like being able to run
like a hundred miles and a short
distance and and do some nice climb like
to combine all these and be able to to
be on yet performing well in both its
kind of very exciting because it means
like how to prepare how to prepare the
different things at the same time and
the recovery and the different skills
that touch very exciting in a pointer
and then in like I mean in running
itself like kids it's maybe like a few
races that I would like to perform a bit
better but yeah like probably in inter
running now is not where I get the more
like excitement but yeah in
mountaineering like last year Everest
like it was very interesting for me not
because what I did that it was like mmm
not that big run away like but it was
mostly love a big deal no but like no
about like climbing Everest without
oxygen it has been climb many times and
the only interesting thing was the
recovery in the climatization so that's
what I learned like how to acclimatize
on how to I was able to spend so many
hours in high altitude and even if I
wasn't feeling good I was able to move
so that give me there's of like why not
to do some link ups or like combine like
long distance in high altitude and I
think that that come interesting for
realization that combination your
ability to handle the acclimatization
and the recovery like how can you then
apply it to a new challenge that would
be interesting yeah anyway that's moving
forward too because like people have
said well do you want to go back to
Everest and see if you can do it faster
and you're somebody who's always looking
forward like that that
not as interesting to you as flying
something new yes especially like I
think it's it's always possible to go
faster like and when you do one time you
see the mistakes you have done so like
but going back and doing faster like
it's it's like it's a big travel so it's
better to do something different than
than the same time just like a few few
minutes or hour faster so but like I
seem in high altitude like link ups are
very interesting meaning like going from
one mountain yeah from one wanting to
the other or like very long bridges like
bridges between mountains because there
you need to to be fast to do it because
the speed it's it's one of the only
possibility to spend like to do these
distances in in high altitude yeah and
the other is like yeah it's a bit more
challenging on technical skills so these
things are yeah are interesting now yeah
the ability to be creative like you're
sort of inventing this thing as you go
it's not purely running it's not purely
skiing it's not purely mountaineering
it's this hybrid of all of these skills
that you've been doing for a very long
time and it's your ability to like take
a paintbrush in like paint this canvas
with what you're able to do in your own
unique way yeah it's interesting like I
think looking to the Past like a lot of
people have been doing a lot of things
so it's not that we are inventing
anything but it's interesting to to do
yeah to be able to look in a map or to
be able to look you know in a mountain
in a picture and to imagine something to
do because you you like to do it not
because it's something that it's a like
famous or something that it's on the
history or everything but just like to
be there and say okay that looks like
amazing to like it looks fun to to run
from the trees to the other order to to
look them up and say like wow that looks
really fun to to follow this line right
well now that you're so well known I
mean you're this you know kind of global
figure when you make a decision about
what your challenge
is gonna be there's a lot of people who
are like paying attention to that and
have an opinion about it you know do you
are you able to like block all of that
out and have the clarity to just do what
your heart is telling you to do or do
you find yourself being influenced by
all these externalities that really
weren't part of the equation when you
begin all of this like we are always
influenced and unlike its influence can
be good and can be bad and and I think
it's it's it's it's me or it's or
certain we need to decide which
influencers are cool or not and and I
think it's many that they are really
right like especially today like for
example social media I think it has a
lot of good things and a lot of bad
things and the good thing is is that now
we can see like what other people is
doing and I don't know like for example
you are saying like Alex Honnold like
what he is doing it's very different of
what I am doing but it gives me a lot of
inspiration for doing some things or
what calling Holly is doing or what
other author honors and that can give me
ideas of what to do so that's like good
influences and then it's also like the
what they say but influences that is
people saying you should do that or like
you should do that in this way or like
it can be like the the pressure like you
could feel from I don't know like
prayers or like our fans or response or
that but I I think I'm I'm in a moment
where I don't really care about these
much and I know like okay I I ran and I
I do racing and that's on a way like my
way of living but what I want to do in
the mountains it's more like for
pleasure and for like this kind of
testing and I'm saying if things is
possible so I I really want to do these
on my way and and and the projects I
they're really motivated especially
because like it's not arise that you can
say okay even if I'm not motivated I can
go through like if you are doing a
project in the mountains and if you are
not hundred percent in there like if
it's a problem is
that you lose their right is that you
die so right the consequences are hardly
it could not be you know could not be
higher but I think on the law along the
lines of the similarities between you
and Alex you know Alex is somebody who
has been very conscious and diligent
about creating a lifestyle that's
conducive to allowing him to do the
thing that he loves the most right like
removing all of those external pressures
and keeping his life very simple so that
he has the most amount of time to do the
things that not only he's best at but
that move him like in and he's able to
do what he's what he's able to do
because he's fully integrated like he
takes this talent and this passion and
what moves him and his heart and his
passions and he puts it all together and
it gets expressed when he climbs up al
Capitan and I see you as someone very
similar like you've made this conscious
decision to leave Sean money to live in
Norway where you know life is a little
bit simpler and everything that you love
is right outside your door and you can
just go be the person that you're meant
to be and the races that you've won and
the FK T's and Everest and all of that
is just an expression of this passion
and you're this integrated human being
who can take this whatever God give
gifted talent you have combined it with
what gets you excited and out of bed
every morning and put it all together to
express yourself in this way that's
almost you know it's as artistic as it
is athletic yeah it's and it's I think
it's hard to do that nowadays because we
get so much with like inertia it it
takes a lot of people today I think like
we it's we tend to do what it's the
simple thing the sample thing and to try
to do what's easy and what it's supposed
to be and we don't take time to to find
what we want to do and not what we are
supposed to do and but there like when
you find that that's what you want to do
want to find that the the balance of
that it's much
it's just the life it's much better like
everything around it's much better but
yeah I suppose it just like it needs to
it need some courage or it need some
like seeing some time okay I don't want
to that and to be able to say no I don't
want to that and I want to to cut on
things and maybe that means less medics
position or less money or less I don't
know things that they are supposed to
drive you through through success but
they're like how you have you count
success it's very different yeah yeah so
what is living outside the comfort zone
taught you like this this ability to be
comfortable with being uncomfortable
like how is that a teacher for you and
what can be learned from that well I
think it did you it's mostly decision
taking like how to how to take decisions
how you take the decisions in the in the
zone like to be always exposed like to
not be sure about what's going on and to
able to be really rational on on seeing
very fast
what are they the different consequences
on each decision you are taking at that
period I think that you can apply on on
life and you can apply on on everything
else and yeah it's I think it's to be a
really cold blood but to become law to
follow your your emotions and that's
that's kind of contradictory but they're
like is you want you need to to listen
to your emotion order to listen to your
to yourself to see where you want to go
watch the lifestyle you want to have
once the things you want to achieve and
that that need to be your emotion that
decides this but then the decision
taking through there you need to be
really like rational yeah
what uh what what scares you the most
well many things I would say like of
course like when going out like dying or
like having like a big accident things
like that but I think what scares me in
more general it's like where where are
we going
like the war like now we see like all
the environmental problems and
especially when you are in in in these
areas like with a lot of glaciers that
you can see they were they almost how
it's changing so on this way like where
are we going as as the planet and that's
something that it's scurrying yen and I
think that and where were associated
like all the the problems between humans
that we have all the the with yeah it's
a lot of conflicts human conflicts too
and I think that's that's more scary
than not then like dying
the future of humanity yeah yeah
humanity but humanity like yeah we are
one is peace more of the plants also the
planet - yeah the planet - well the
planet would be fine without us somebody
who's seen much more of it than then I
you can attest to that I would imagine
what do you think people misunderstand
about you I don't know I don't care I
think yeah but not healthy ya know I
think yeah it's like probably like the
first years like when you get the
tension you are you get attention and
you want to to take care of these aliens
I would say but they're like you need to
be yourself and you need to do things
that you do and you know that some
people will yet like you some people
will not like you some people will
understand some
but if you put your life only to to make
a solution on that like you then like
you will not live your life so yeah yeah
but it must be weird it must have been
weird when suddenly started getting a
lot of press and there's like New York
Times and all these people are like
writing about you and you're just like
literally this kid who just likes to run
long distances in the mountains
yeah sure that it's something that is
not that I was looking for and it's
something that of course like everybody
likes attention and everybody likes like
people liking them but it also takes a
lot of energy like I I'm not very social
alright not social at all like I in
general like to be kind of alone like
two persons it's ok 3 it's it's too much
yeah well you're gonna have 3 in your
house soon yeah yeah that's ok but yeah
it's this kind of thing so but yeah so
then it needs to find a good balance
with like this energy and these moments
to to recharge energy yeah and what's uh
what if you could do anything in a
typical day like what does that look
like just you going at your front door
and getting lost in the mountains yeah
like a typical day like it's just like
waking up like not very early like 6:30
7:00 I've done it might be like first
normally like if I'm home like just a
glass of water and maybe yeah like one
cookie or like Emily she baked cinnamon
buns that they are delicious or maybe
one of those in the morning and then I
go for a run in summer ski in the winter
I'm depending like weather conditions
and if I feel good like that can be
between two two to five hours or some
days like I do longer like a 10-15 hours
but normally more like two to five hours
then come back home a bit of work like
mails and logistics like preparing
things and then in the
normally go for like one hour run or
like one short training some I can go to
the climbing gym or or do some small
exercises home and then I like breathing
so in the afternoon like I like to just
take take a book and read what kind of
stuff do you like to read novels and
essays and things like like that so yeah
like now for example now in this travel
around like a has been reading some
Foster Wallace books and like some
Spanish books like Catalan capital and
outdoors or Milan Kundera some books of
Milan Kundera or at least I'm very coy I
really like them yeah do you have
mentors in your life like people that
you seek advice from yeah I have some
people like George Eaters and Jordi
coterminous is two to two Catalan
climbers that they they they were the
first ones to took me to the malleus and
actually the first expedition with it it
was only the three of us we had like
small backpacks like 30 40 litres
backpack and we were going like from
very far away to climb high mountains
very minimalistic we were eating like
one portion of Leo food for the three of
us per day so yeah it was kind of this
Thailand I always consult with them when
things on that and probably my first
coats Jordy canals he he was the one
that started to coach me when I started
the ski mountaineering and we talk
almost every week about like training
life and he's also very geek like when
when I had doubts about like some
algorithm that I'm looking for like for
training or for like performance things
or or things like that
yeah is there one to control say yeah
maybe we need to find a way there yeah
and Julie stack was kind of a mentor as
well right like you learned a lot about
mountaineering from him
yeah II was someone that first I admired
a lot when when he was starting to or
when I was starting to to to raise and
to to be in the mountains like he was
doing all these things incredible feats
and and it was like wow what's that's
that incredible and then actually we
meet a few times we were starting we
climb some things together right and
only like going to a climb they with him
it was just like learning so much every
every second yeah and then he passed
away you guys were both in Nepal but on
different mountains when that occurred
right yeah actually he was in Everest in
the south side and I I was in the north
side and
when when it happened I was with Emily
in in show you and I says get the news
and it's yeah it's thing moments that
like that our heart in a way because
first you you lose a friend but then
like us because the the value system you
have like everybody has like a way to
look to live or the activities with you
and and really had a way that has I were
really inspired on and we shared a lot
of things so when he had an accident or
or people that follow this way have an
accident is like all these system of
values is like falling down and then is
like all the questions like the race we
are taking are worth it or like it's
it's stupid what I'm doing I was there
with Emily is like okay like I was
thinking or like Willie's wife and
saying okay it's it's it's worth it or
not and I think at the end like it's
what we need to live like it's if we
want to preserve live like we will be in
a coach everyday like just not going out
because everything can happen but then
like if we if it's a possibility of
dying it means that we are living -
mmhmm yeah put you in - in touch in
connection with something that we're all
I have to yeah white I mean that's
another thing I talked to Alex about at
length like I think he's able to live
his life much more present and aware
because it's so connected to death at
every moment and it I think it infuses
his life with a little bit more vitality
and and perspective like we in America
we all sort of tend to believe it's not
going to happen and we try to you know
prevent any aspect of death for from
being in our you know line of sight but
when it's episode of course it's good
and there's something about like there's
something healthy I think about you know
connecting with it in that way and you
know certainly this is what you were
born to do like it's not like you're
gonna not do it and in some ways it's
honoring Lily for you to continue you
know what he would have wanted you to do
ya know I think it's like this
connection with with the risk and with
like seeing that there's close like it's
very visual like when ya when you are
like soloing or when you are like
steepest King or like putting yourself
in some risky places like it really
beats well like you say okay if I do
that I'm dead but that's that's also and
every day it's only that we don't see
like I was saying like when you are
driving a highway like if you do a
stupid thing you will die but you will
not do it but I think probably when you
do these activities like in Montana ring
or or in climbing like this the feeling
of like having the control of that like
saying okay I I am controlling now like
on how I put my feet on how I put my
hands on how I do these on how I
Traverse this place I have the control
of like living or dying it gives you a
sense of more responsibility thing about
your life it's like with the playing it
gives you a so yeah this perspective or
like I
yeah like on only doing the things that
you want to do and that they are
important for you because you realize
like it can go very fast so why to spend
time doing things that they don't mean
anything at the end and with that in
mind and what is what is the legacy that
you would like to leave when it's all
said and done not one I think like just
like that we need to live our life as
like that it's that nothing we do is
that I think we are so much about we
want to leave a legacy or we want to to
be remember or we want to do something
important and then nothing we do it's
important like it's yeah it's is nothing
and I think when you realize that we are
not important and what we do is not
important then you realize how wonderful
it is
yeah well that's back to the humility or
is back to live and I think in spite you
to being human and to being yeah just
just a small thing that's beautifully
put well I need to release you to your
life and let you let you go but I want
to close this down by reading a passage
at the end of your book that that really
struck me and I'm interested in in you
elaborating on it and it goes like this
a great athlete is one who takes
advantage of the ability that genetics
have brought him in order to secure the
great achievements but an exceptional
athlete is one who can swim in the
waters of complexity and chaos making
what seems difficult easy creating order
from chaos yeah as you say yeah its
order from chaos that's that's
performance I would say because it's so
many things that they are not supposed
to do happen like that and you are able
to put all together and that's that
words when you see when you see the path
on a place that it's it's rough that
it's not logical is when you can see
clear I think
cool good talking you man no thank you
very much
thanks for coming it was a pleasure I
appreciate it very much
super inspiring I wish you well
especially with the impending new
arrival yeah I hated luck surviving the
big city yeah no Nicks patients first
yeah yeah if you if you want to connect
with Killian he's easy to find on the
internet on instagrams probably the best
place right people want to see beautiful
pictures and yeah like yeah that's what
they do to put my a zone on beautiful
places and put in Instagram and his book
runner die I highly recommend it it's a
beautiful book and the new documentary
which you're also promoting right now
about the the Everest attempt can you
tell us a little bit about that yeah we
are we were working last year on putting
the images of of all it is not only
about the Everest experience Seb was
there and said was filming in the
mountain but it's also like summits of
my life oh yes savage of my life and
coming back from why I ended up doing
Everest in the way I did like all the
the moments in my life that were
important you to drive to there and if
people are listening who want to check
it out word where do they go to view it
is it'll be streaming online it's gonna
be streaming online so like they they
will be able to find in my social media
in my website all right cool and I'll
put a link up in the show notes so that
so people can find it thank you how do
you feel feel good like yeah no it's
it's what time is it on your internal
thank you like the internal clock like
now it's is not anymore here we were
beyond space and time right yeah alright
thanks so much man appreciate it
peace plants running
[Music]